[Music]
it's time for ETS social study a quick
look at what the stars are posting
online
Ashley green shared with the world this
magical video of she and boyfriend Paul
Khoury getting engaged while on a hike
in New Zealand sweetly captioning the
video this is the most beautiful moment
I could have ever hoped for
Shakira's husband gerard piqué posted
that adorable video to his account of he
and the couple's three-year-old son
Milan singing together Chris Martin also
put his folks to work over the holidays
paying tribute to the late George
Michael for the crisis homeless charity
in London Simpsons husband Evan Ross
also got in the holiday spirit with
their daughter Jagger posting this
adorable pic of the one-year-old
dressed up like a reindeer
[Music]
meanwhile Olympic gold-medalist Simone
biles was not receiving the love over
her social media posts of the rockin
beach bod while vacationing in Belize
the 19 year old gymnasts shut down the
haters with one epic tweet writing you
all can judge my body all you want but
at the end of the day it's my body I
love it and uncomfortable in my skin at
the end of the day if you do that you've
won yourself
you